so now that we have a working asset
manager it's probably worth taking a
step back and talking about how good
asset loading works in good games si
proper asset loading means you need to
take into account how a users going to
experience your game and benefit from
that properly so for instance if you are
on a cd-rom drive you have to know that
it's gonna take a certain amount of time
to actually stream data from the disk
into memory so you have to pretty much
cover that by doing some three-second
animation or something else to hide from
the user that's streaming overhead now
some very interesting examples of this
come to mind the first is probably one
of the more famous ones Devil May Cry
back in the original playstation 2 this
game had a really cool mode that while
the scene was actually loading if you
did your button smashing you'd actually
do damage the loading bar IRA actually
remember sitting in my room watching my
roommate kind of smashed on this button
controller as mad as possible because he
was so angry that it was taking so long
to load but by the time the level
actually loaded
he was happy again and could go on
killing all sorts of demons the second
example that comes to mind is actually
Metroid Prime for the Gamecube this was
actually a simplistic tunnel shooter
effectively you had segments of geometry
that your player would move through over
time they did something really cool is
that they only allowed one section of
tunnel in memory at a time this meant
that each tunnel could be super
high-resolution graphics because there
was nothing else competing for space as
you moved towards the end of a tunnel
though towards one of those little doors
you got to shoot to open it would start
streaming in the next level the problem
with this though was if you started
running too fast you would get to the
door before the streaming was done
you sit there shooting the door and it
wouldn't open yet because the next level
hadn't loaded my personal favorite is
actually jak and daxter these guys had
probably one of the earliest streaming
mechanisms that I ever found and the
coolest way to hide it too they had an
infinite terrain so you could run around
and do all sorts of stuff but if you for
some reason we're able to move fast
enough that you were moving in an area
that the terrain hadn't been streamed
off of disk yet they'd trip your player
this is the only time in the entire game
where your player would actually fall
down and then play a three to four
second get up animation of course during
that time they had plenty of extra space
to spin up the rest of the data from the
disk the point is this most
game development is smoke and mirrors so
take advantage of that to give your user
a believable experience